I was born in England Oxford I grew up
in in mostly in southern England so that
very much shaped my the way I speak in
my culture and went to school there I
went to Oxford University and then you
know in the profession I chose chose I
very luckily got to work in in the
States I married an American and have
lived here since the early 70s well you
know it's it I keep hustling about this
the actors role I mean as a young person
I was honestly impressed reading things
that Laurence Olivier said that the the
actors function in society was as
important as a psychiatrist because he
took it back to the the old
Shakespearean thing of holding the
mirror up to nature and allowing people
to understand what made people tick and
how they related and so on in a very
user friendly way of the drama you know
and then if you want to be really
pretentious you take it back to you know
to ancient Greece what was happening
there and this impressed me also the
fact that I I found I had a facility
before performing and enjoyed it and
then in particular I I was very lucky to
live near London in the suburbs and in
the late 50s when I was about 16 a
remarkable man called Michael Kraft
started the Youth Theatre which became
over time the National Youth Theatre of
Great Britain very well respected
respected and an integral part of
English culture and there's hardly an
actor who was of note who hasn't been
through the Youth Theatre I think of
contemporaries Dame Helen Mirren and
there's Daniel Craig and Derek Jacobi
everyone and this was important because
at the
sixteen I was performing Shakespeare in
Paris I was representing my nation you
know and so this it became very heady
and and as I said Oxford University was
a great unofficial drama school because
it was happening on every level from
classic cult you know culture to
experimental theatre to also comedy
particularly in up in the Edinburgh
Festival up on the fringe you know there
was a great tradition of taking it you
know a show and my contemporaries at
Oxford where one half of the Monty
Python's Michael Palin Terry Jones and
so we were doing those that kind of
comedy stuff they had the genius to take
this and put it out into the wider world
and God bless him for it so I even at
university I wasn't sure that this is
you know what I wanted to do but I'd met
so many academics who I felt it somehow
had this interest in the drama but had
sort of stopped short of plunging into
the unknown world of show business and
had stayed in the familiar territories
of a Canada territory of Academy and
somehow were vicariously fulfilling
their interest through the in the
theatre through that through their
students I didn't want that I thought
well I'll do it I don't want to live my
life knowing I could have done it and
hadn't dared so I became an actor and I
thought I'd see what you know how it
what happened
you